to get capacity back up to 100 clark
county officials wanted to see a 60
vaccination rate and right now we're
hovering just around
50 percent for those who are 18 and
older joe moeller is live outside the
health district with what needs to
happen next joe
well the health district says come
tomorrow clark county commissioners will
be meeting to discuss whether or not
they want to make changes to that
mitigation plan well meanwhile the
health district
is working to get as many pop-up clinics
out there to make it more convenient
for people to get their shot got my
second shot more and more people are
getting the vaccine so i decided
why not but is it enough it's kind of a
relief to know that i at least have
vaccinations it's a raise against the
clock we are seeing more vaccine pop-ups
like this one outside the first golden
knights playoff game
another one is set for tuesday's game
the clark county fire department is
doing what they can
and the city of henderson is making it
easy with this clinic inside the
galleria mall
it makes a huge difference if it's where
you work
if it's a place that you frequent dr
christine madison from roseman
university says convenience plays a role
about 50 percent of eligible adults have
received at least
one shot the goal is 60 percent by june
1st to reopen fully
those predictions were made when our
vaccination rates were really at their
peak
vaccinations have slowed down in recent
weeks dr madison says she thinks more
people will get a shot if they get
something in return
incentives right like that's what's
going to get people through the door so
if it's the difference between me
getting my vaccine and not getting me
back
my vaccine but maybe i can get like a
free buntini or maybe i get a ticket to
a show or a sporting event cody mashburn
got shot number two and thinks
incentives could work
just random free things from businesses
or something like that you know like hey
get a shot have a shot bartender ethan
coates says reopening at 100 percent
impacts a lot of people
my well-being the way i you know make my
money
it affects so many different aspects so
just go get it done man
now back out here live the pop-ups are
happening at more and more places the
hustlers strip club is even having one
of their own
come this friday there and also tomorrow
the golden knights are still having one
before the game in toshiba plaza
you can get a complete list of those
pop-ups that are happening in the coming
weeks up on our website eightnewsnow.com
reporting live here at the health
district joe mohler 8 news now